ed davey
can i just start with
this morning's story uh wouldn't lib dem
government continue to pay the french
police 54 million
a year to fail to stop illegal crossings
well first of all we change the policy
on dealing with the crossings
pretty patel's policy the conservative
policy is not working as we've seen
we're seeing increasing number of
crossings and there the reason why their
uh shrill and strategies aren't working
because they're not dealing with the
root cause
what we would do is ensure there are
safe routes for people who are trying to
come to this country
resettlement schemes family reunion
schemes these exist and they should be
developed further and that would mean
many many people would not put
themselves at great risk and cause this
problem in the first place
but trevor if we're talking about what
the government said it would do with the
french
it appears that there's a complete
disagreement between the french and the
british at the moment it seems according
to the french minister that pretty patel
has reneged on her deal
and if she's reneged on a deal that is
obviously going to cause lots of
problems on the french side so
from what i know
uh it looks like the british government
isn't paying its bills and that's
causing the problem
okay let's um
talk about energy you were energy
secretary for three years um
did you support the introduction of the
price cap
well when it came in and as it's used
now yes i do i do think we need to
protect consumers from these rising
bills is unprecedented rises in people's
heating bills and the power bills and
they need some protection i'd actually
go further and i was slightly concerned
about the way quasi quatern talked about
this he doesn't seem to realize there
are millions of people
who are on very low income vulnerable
people hardworking people on low incomes
who are going to face a real crisis a
cost of living crisis over the coming
months
and he didn't seem to engage with that
and the price cap is a protection but
when it comes to things like the most
vulnerable two million households in
fuel poverty there is a mechanism he
actually mentioned it's called warm
homes discount
what i would do
is i would double or triple that warm
homes discount takes 140 pounds off uh
people's bills and i would want to
extend it to more low-income households
let's remember they've just cut
universal credit by 20 pounds a week i i
thought that was outrageous thing to do
because it's going to mean millions of
low-paid working
families in real crisis so if they're
going to proceed with that appalling cut
the very least they can do the very
least when people are struggling with
these high heating bills is to look at
something like the warm homes discount
and that's what liberal democrats would
do today we would double triple that and
extend that support for people's energy
bills to to more people who are who are
hard working but on low incomes
so um in in essence uh spend some more
billions
well i think it actually is not it's not
billions actually it's hundreds of
millions um it would target that support
on the people who are going to struggle
the people who may end up having to
choose between eating and eating
the government's already giving local
authorities 500 million for that purpose
aren't they
well that purpose is mainly true as i've
understood it to replace the six billion
cut they're making universal credit and
what's important if you look at their
statement it almost uses exactly the
same words you've just used which is
that it is targeted at the most
vulnerable
well um i'm very worried about the
approach they're taking they're taking
six billion pounds from the most
vulnerable and replacing with just 500
million in a system which isn't clear
how it's going to get to people but
they have the system that i'm talking
about is in place it could be triggered
tomorrow and the reason why i think the
conservatives aren't doing it
is what you saw from quasi quad saying
they don't really care about these
households and more than that let's
remember they were wanting to get rid of
this warm home discount when i've talked
to tourists they they refuse to admit
that something called fuel poverty even
exists
so liberal democrats are determined to
be with the millions of households who
are going to struggle this winter with
their heating bills and we're proposing
the warm homes discount rise as a method
do you know there's other things they
should be doing as well um back in labor
government days there was lots of
insulation programs so people didn't
have to use so much gas so their heating
bills were lower as secular state i
continued
those programs we insulated
a hundred thousand over a million homes
i'm very proud of that and that meant
those heating bills were will be reduced
despite the uh higher costs the
conservatives have absolutely failed to
insulate people's homes so people who
are in fuel poverty people are really
struggling don't even even have that
protection so whether it's warm homes
out where it's insulating uh people's
bills i'm really worried that the
government don't seem to be providing
the healthcare or
to consumers